morning everyone
like today you've all day we started
over hands on heads I don't know it's
made that up like what's with the whole
intonation in there I always provide
actually its shades for a stain right so
do you think I should teach a whole
lesson I don't know well idea that
actually get they are prescription which
is why I'm not blind you actually it's
good right room I can still see just ran
up okay why not yeah yeah that's
whistling won't let me waste okay how
much you got any other concentrate these
are your attention on the boy this was
actually oh yeah she did it all the time
I'm looking at everyone so this was
actually like um I don't know if you
remember a couple of years ago Toby sure
I shaved my head fur for what's it
called well its greatest [ __ ] yeah we
figure yeah anyway and I had a I had my
ipt class the next lesson like after
lodge and like yeah I was always I was
teaching in every was just kind of lunch
staring turn league don't worry when I
was anyway I don't think this is quite
as bad before you get used to it